[Música]
muy buenas tardes a todos un gusto para
nosotros estar aquí compartiendo nuestra
experiencia con los sonidos de las
plantas
tenemos un público muy selecto que tal
vez en otra ocasión no nos vamos a
encontrar así que vamos a aprovechar al
máximo para hacerle llegar nuestro
mensaje tanto tapado como yo hemos
buscado desde nuestra experiencia como
músicos la relación entre arte y
naturaleza entre arte y sonido grabamos
un disco que se llama simbiosis que tal
vez muchos de ustedes lo conocen en
donde dialoga vamos en vivo en
monteverde con los sonidos
diferentes plantas también de animales
del viento de los volcanes en fin toda
la naturaleza que tenemos en costa rica
tapado también grabó un disco que se
llama mística
nativa y tiene
pues hemos trabajado muchos años juntos
con diferentes grupos pero siempre esta
búsqueda de conocer qué es este mensaje
que nos están dando
y los diferentes elementos naturales
hace ya unos 15 años en un concierto en
holanda tuve la oportunidad de conocer
por primera vez esta tecnología que es
desarrollada
en torino italia en donde también
después de muchos años de experimentar
lograron sacar los primeros sonidos de
seres vivos no sólo desde plantas sino
de todo lo que tiene las condiciones
para emitir sonidos lo cual nos abre una
puerta y nos permite comunicarnos aún
en un primer nivel con lo que las
plantas nos están diciendo
es un momento importante también este
que estamos viviendo a nivel global en
donde hay muchísimos
sectores de nuestros bosques
desapareciendo y no sólo por el tema
económico verdad o por la inclusión de
agricultura de ganadería u otros se
prioriza verdad a veces la actividad
económica sobre este
esta gran banco que tenemos de
conocimiento que son nuestros bosques
que son nuestros seres vivientes de ahí
la importancia de sensibilizar a todo
nivel
lo que nos están diciendo las plantas
entonces vamos a iniciar con un pequeño
experimento nada más escuchando estas
estos sonidos
y después de escuchar los que cada uno
pues vaya pensando que que está diciendo
esta planta
estamos escuchando primero esta matriz y
después invitamos a mi hija jimena a
quien ella es bióloga y está trabajando
en un tema muy interesante que es la
bioacústica para que les explique
exactamente qué es lo que está pasando
aquí posteriormente vamos a dialogar
nosotros con estas plantas de forma que
vamos a ir tocando siguiendo la melodía
que ellas van metiendo
[Música]
buenas noches
bueno esto que estamos escuchando
como explicaba mi papá de esta planta
que está por aquí
es una p pero mía en la familia la
pimienta
y bueno ustedes imagino la mayoría no se
imagina que una planta pueda expresarse
comunicar algo
entonces
bueno me gustaría ponernos a pensar una
planta que tiene un
como cecil verdad una planta no se puede
mover entonces
le resulta muy útil tener
mecanismos para emitir o recibir señales
como lo es el sonido verás resulta muy
útil comunicarse de esa forma
[Música]
más allá de eso sabemos que las plantas
no cuentan con estructuras
especializadas para recibir sonido o
emitiendo verdad no tienen cuerdas gales
ni oídos
entonces
es ahí donde los invitamos a pensar en
cómo formas de comunicación alternativa
verdad
y también podemos ponernos a pensar cuál
fue la evolución de este tipo de
organismos en donde evidentemente en sus
orígenes no estaban aislados como
tenemos hoy aquí está sus macetas sino
que evolucionaron en interacción con el
medio ambiente con otras plantas con los
animales entonces bueno sabemos que las
plantas son seres de luz y de agua
ver a ellos reciben como aprendimos en
nuestras clases de fotosíntesis reciben
la luz y la transforman en energía
química entonces esta electricidad que
pasa a través de sus tejidos son tenidos
acuosos
entonces podríamos imaginarnos que el
interior de una planta funciona como un
circuito eléctrico en una piscina y
tenemos las paredes celulares de cada
una de las células de la planta que
funcionan como aislante por lo tanto no
nos electrocutado más cuando tocamos es
una planta verdad
pero bueno
que estamos escuchando realmente verdad
la máquina que es esta que tenemos aquí
y funciona realizando una transición de
la señal eléctrica y la transforma en
una señal acústica estos pulsos
eléctricos que realiza la planta en su
metabolismo eran naturalmente por la
energía y el agua que corren a través de
ella
son pulsaciones eléctricas que la
máquina puede transformar y
bueno a continuación vamos a percibir
como al igual que los músicos están
utilizando instrumentos para producir
música crear algo la planta va a
utilizar la máquina para crear ella
también sus propios melodías y
bueno ellas son capaces de modificar las
modulaciones son las notas
y perciben y que ellos emiten entonces
van a poder armonizar con lo que los
músicos van a ir interpretando
básicamente y muchas gracias
necesitamos
una última cosita para que vean que
sigue la planta vamos a hacer un cambio
aquí
de esta planta está entonces el
funcionamiento
básicamente bueno tenemos un gel que
ayuda a conducir la electricidad es como
cuando no le ponen en el hospital un
pelado un electrodo también entonces se
le ve se le pone un gel a la hoja
vamos a poner quitar este electrodo de
aquí
y lo ponemos en la hoja
y lleva otro electro que sería el de
tierra
queda conectado a la raíz de esta otra
planta vamos a esperar un momento
porque a veces dura un poquito
volverá
activarse si querer hablar también hemos
descubierto que son un poco tímidos
también algunas plantas no todas se
comunican de igual forma
entonces verá y ya está está también
hablando
vamos a ver cómo cantan entonces con la
música es diferente
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
es
ah
[Música]
es todo
no tengo
[Música]
sí
d
[Música]
bueno
qué
[Música]
a él
no no
[Música]
[Aplausos]